pascal est ce que par amour du prochain
vous pourriez coucher avec une femme
âgée oui sans problème sans problème et
je vous pourriez coucher avec un homme
ça c'est bon s'il le fallait je pense
qu'en prison dans des conditions
spéciales la sexualité se portent sur
tous les objets par deux chesnot et
malbrunot là tout à l'heure tu aurais dû
lui dire en face quand je est-ce que
vous pourriez coucher qu'une mineure par
amour du prochain une phase de travail
dans les mines les ce moment je le faire
non là non là ça me gênerait avec une
prostituée pas de problème
oui avec une mini jean beast comme paul
mccartney
on va peut-être pas mais mon héros pour
le ferai valoir avec une fille très très
très très très moche
oui pas de problème si très très très
très très salll j'ai pas là mais c'est
lent là on est moins chère formant ses
pas il hésite
aucune fille très très très très conne
oh oui ça sans problème non mais c'est
parce qu'il faut l'accepter alors là
c'est vous dire est ce que vous pourriez
coucher avec une fille qui dit malgré
que à la place de bien que oui parce que
moi je le dis aussi disent contrôler
l'une qui dit par contre au lieu de en
revanche présent pourriez vous s'il n'y
a pas de problème non ça c'est pas c'est
pas oui tu sais qu'on ne dit pas on dit
pas par contre marie l'eau ne savait pas
mal
thomas non tu vas trop loin après les
jeux non je sais c'est dur pas d'accord
avec un travesti
oui avec un vieux pote un peu bourré de
cuisine ipod cousine pascal wick pas
d'argent avec votre belle mère s'est
déjà fait en ce sens là là vous me posez
une question people non non non je vais
dire non et l'activia qu'elle soit une
très belle très désirable et je vous
voyez coucher avec moi je préférerais
éviter mais s'il le faut en prison
révisée
ouf
mais bon là